do you need a doctor
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease from here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take the
risks
[Music]
if you're gonna run
do it now
then you were found on a container ship
that washed up off a long island
when you're alone
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of you
who wants to hunt
and consume blood
[Music]
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
other half wants to control you hey dr
mike you and i should stay in touch
i'd do anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you matt i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service
[Music]
you